you've also looked at ufo materials you
are in possession of ufo materials
yourself
claimed ufo materials
claims
alleged ufo materials that's right so
what's another term weird materials that
don't seem to uh
uh
have a story
they have a story that doesn't seem to
be of natural origins but
it's not
you know
there's a process to proving that and
that process may
uh take decades if not centuries because
you have to keep pulling it
at the string and discover where they
could possibly come from but anyway you
you're in a possession of some
materials of this kind
can you
describe some of them and maybe also
talk to the process of how you
investigate them how do you analyze them
right so let's say that there's two
classes of materials that i've
been given by people and they're not
given by like the government or anything
just given people who've collected them
and there's a a reasonable chain of
evidence associated with them that you
believe it's not just a pebble somebody
picked up off a road
um
there are almost always things that
people have claimed have either been
dropped off as like some sort of a
leftover material molten metals
or um they are
from
an object that was released from this so
that kind of
exploded
they're almost always metals
i have some couple of things that might
be biological that are interesting that
i haven't really spent a lot of time on
yet
when you look at a metal you basically
well okay what are the elements in it
and what's it made of
and so there's pretty standard
approaches to doing that most of them
involve a technology called mass
spectrometry
and there's probably about five or six
different kinds of mass spectrometry
that you could bring to bear on
answering it
and they either tell you depending upon
the limit of the resolution of the
instrument
they either tell you the elements that
are there
or they tell you the isotopes that are
there and you're interested not just in
knowing whether something is there or
not you're interested in knowing
whether they're uh
you know the
the amounts of it the the and in the
case of
elements
how many different isotopes are there
and and that's kind of where in some of
these cases it gets interesting
right because on in at least one of the
materials
as we first studied it the isotope
ratios of in this case it was magnesium
are way off normal
and
i just don't know why it doesn't it
doesn't prove anything it just all it
proves is that
it was probably
accomplished by some kind of an
industrial process
whether it's the result
of a process or whether and and this is
sort of the leftover
or whether it was made that way for a
particular purpose
i don't know all i know is that
it it was
engineered
that's it right but then it's
the question is
sort of you go one step deeper why would
you engineer it
right well why
and what is the engineered means there's
all kinds of
it could be a byproduct it could be
um
the main result of an engineering
process
it would be a small part of the
engineering process that is the main
part
well so
the ratios of isotopes for any given
element are basically the result of
stellar processes
uh
a supernova blew up
sometime several tens you know several
billion years ago
uh
that became a cloud
those atoms coalesced gravitationally to
form another sun
and a ring that became a rocky planet
uh and the ratios of the isotopes were
determined at the time of that
explosion
and so everything in the local
solar system is more or less of that
ratio depending upon certain
gravitational diff but but by
fragments of a percent not
whole tens of percent difference
so what do humans use isotopes for
mostly to blow stuff up i mean the vast
majority of the isotopes that have been
made in in the per pound or ton
are things like
certain ratios of plutonium and uranium
to blow stuff up
we don't make
or engineer isotopes which it's it's
today is relatively easy to do but it's
still expensive
for any other reason apart from let's
say
as
anti-cancer
we use stable isotopes in money
these days as a counterfeiting tool you
basically embed certain ratios of
isotopes in to make it harder for
counterfeiters to accomplish
um
and so but other than that we don't do
anything with that so why would you make
grams of such material in this one case
and drop it around on a beach in brazil
so which case we're talking about this
is this is the ubertuba case
can you describe this case a little bit
further like what material we're talking
about just the full story of the case so
it's an interesting one it's an
interesting one so a fisherman saw an
object
that uh
released something or it it
exploded
and it was this
relative i'm you know i've got some big
chunks of it
uh relatively pure magnesium
with obviously something else in it
because magnesium burns so it had
something in it that would other metals
simple alloy that would prevent it from
from uh basically burning up
um
and so the question is
and so then we had we had two pieces
that came from
um two different chains of custody both
claimed to be from the same object
at least
uh physically when you look at the two
things they look
the same
right
so we took small fragments of each of
them we put them in an instrument called
a secondary ion mass spec
which is an extremely sensitive
instrument and it can see down to 0.0001
mass units
which is important for
let's say more
arcane reasons but
um it's a sensitive instrument and so
one of the chains of custody with two
pieces from the same chain of custody
and then two pieces from the other chain
of custody
one of them had completely normal
uh magnesium isotope ratios magnesium 24
25 26 and the other was off
not just like slightly off way off and
they were both off to the same extent
so
uh
i mean it was sort of like you had an
internal control
of what was normal then you had this
other one which was which was wrong
and so you're left with uh that's what
kind of an open question
was this a hoax were these two chains of
custody one of them a hoax that somebody
purposefully introduced those things
because you could do it it would
cost a lot i mean at the time that this
was found i guess the 1970s or so
um might have been earlier i forget
uh
the amount that i had would have cost
several tens of thousands of dollars to
make um
and again it's not something you would
just throw around and why would you do
it in the hope that some guy 30 years
from then
would
would pick it up and study it that's a
very subtle
it's a long term plan
um so so i i just don't know i just
don't know
what to make of it except it's
interesting but it's but so a different
kind of question that you're asking is
what constitutes evidence
right so is is this
sufficient evidence absolutely not
but somebody's put it forward i have the
time it's my time
i'll study it and i my objective is to
sort of take those that i think are
credible enough
and do a reasonable analysis put it out
there and maybe somebody else will come
up with an idea as to what it is
now what would be better
is some sort of
true
technology right something that is
obviously
we don't have it
you know and
people like
um neil degrasse tyson
and seth shostak have come out
rightfully
and have said
you know when you show up with
you know uh
something
really obviously technology that we
don't understand
you know then we'll pay attention
right not just material not just
material a piece of metal
is is interesting
uh but
and several of the things that i've
looked at and things that people other
things that people have come
to me with we've found to be completely
banal or
were actually pieces of aircraft
that were invented back in the 1940s
yeah and so take them off the table see
but
i think
again i think showing up with technology
that we humans would find completely
novel is actually a really difficult
task for aliens because it obviously
can't be so novel
that we don't recognize it for what it
is for what it is and so and i would say
most the technology aliens likely have
would be something we don't recognize
so they it's actually a hard problem how
to convince ants
like you first have to understand what
ants are tweeting about
like what they care about
in order to like inject into their
culture
because uh
you know that's why i think
it would be the technology that you
could present is in the space of ideas
is in uh
it's tried to influence individual
humans and with the encounters right and
try to with this kind of thing
that you mentioned
about uh
us not taking messages about us not
taking care of the world
it's difficult
i mean i to for them to understand you
have to come up with trinkets that
impress us i mean maybe the very
technology
the fascination with the development of
technology and the development of
technology the actual act of innovation
itself
is the thing that they're communicating
right i mean this is kind of what you
know jacques valet thinks about
is the role of
the control system he calls it the
control system
you